[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 46th episode of chess trap
series
in today's lecture i am going to show
you a beautiful
trap in the sarat gambit which is in
fact
very common at the club level tournament
practice
the critical position arises after the
following opening model
e4 e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 d4
e catches d4 and now we have the scotch
gambit
on the table with bishop to c4
well against it there are two popular
choices
but here we are only going to
concentrate on the move bishop to c5
after this if you recall in my dirty
chastic sixth episode
i have covered the dangerous max slang
attack
in detail starting with castle on the
king side
however here white has
another aggressive choice namely
knight to g5 starting point
of our senate gambit
so as you can see there is a double
attack on f7 and accordingly
black has two choices
well our main trap occurs when black
plays the moon knight v5
however there are few words about knight
to at 6
because after this move we are going to
deal the position in a similar manner
knight captures app 7 this beautiful
sarat sacrifice black has no option
he has to take it and now you see the
point behind this whole sacrifice
dwight has this nice sequence bishop
captures f7
king takes f7 and now the sting in the
tail
queen to h5 jack not only regaining the
peace
but if you carefully look at this
position
black has severely weakened the dark
squares
and his king is wide open which gives
a good attacking chance to the white
camp
here it doesn't matter whether black
continues with d6 or d5
white's overall aim is he wants to
quickly castle on the king's side
and then become hell loose on this weak
king
so that is how you should respond if you
open and continue with
knight to h6
the most interesting part about this
position is
if you check the online database there
are more than
250 games continue with knight to e5
which looks more logical in this
position
not only defending on f7 but also
attacking of a bishop
and that way the g8 knight will remain
the flexible
well yup everything looks so good except
one problem that
black has straight away fallen into the
white
trap territory and the trappy business
start with
once again this dazzling sacrifice on f7
yup you guessed it knight captures ap7
attacking two major pieces and
accordingly
black has two choices
the majority of the game continue with
knight captures f7
and that's where our main trap springs
into the action
as after the following sequence bishop
captures up seven
king takes f7 queen to h5 jack
g6 and queen capture c5
if you carefully look at this position
there is no knight
on c6 and that means the d4 pawn
is a goner and if that disappear from
the board
not only white become a clear pawn up
but again in the scenario where black
has open king
and these dark squares are weak white is
almost getting the winning advantage
last but not least what happens if black
find our intention
and save the bishop with this sneaky
check
well no issues because we are going to
counter-attack this bishop
with the move c3 and after pontix
and pawn takes in the view of
black queen is hanging black is obliged
to remove this knight
with knight captures f7 but after that
our tasks become very easy as
we are going to capture this strong
bishop
and now if you compare this position
this is an upgrade version of the danish
gambit
where not only black king is caught in
the center
but because of lack of f-pawn and
white has a bishop pair it is only white
who enjoys the advantage and get
a very good attacking metal cave
not so surprising even though there is a
equal material on the board
chess engine gives white a clear plus
one
advantage
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trap in the sarat gambit
remember in this position if you open
and continue with this obvious looking
move
knight to e5 then don't forget to punish
him
with this wonderful sacrifice on f7
which
no matter however black plays
it is only white who get the quick
opening advantage
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care